would you be celibate for a year to be  able to have sex with any girl you  wanted after the year was up yes a  hundred percent yes yes yes yes and i  think you know who it would be  for the best no you wouldn't have sex  taylor swift would you  i'm not gonna say yes because i don't  want to like that's like rude to her if  she doesn't want it but but it's also  rude if you say no yes  you think so  more than anyone you think that she's  like kinky and like good in bed or you  just want to do it just want to like  hold her you're such a [ __ ] weirdo  okay i swear i think i'm gay i i'm just  you're gay for taylor swift i really  love her a lot and i what and i would  but i would only if she wanted to  obviously i feel bad even answering that  question and  you're ruining my channel